.
* Miauen *
Schon als Kind träumten sie davon,
mal Tierärztin zu werden:
Florence, Alix und Éléonore
stiegen mit viel Leidenschaft
in ihren Traumberuf ein.
Aber sie merkten schnell,
dass die Realität anders aussieht.
Der Berufsalltag einer Tierärztin
bringt viele Schwierigkeiten,
viel Unerwartetes,
aber auch viel Freude.
Hier sind sie:
die neuen Tierärztinnen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Vogelzwitschern *
* Ruhige, klassische Musik *
Éléonore arbeitet im Kanton Freiburg.
Sie erhielt gerade
einen Anruf von einem Bauern.
Herr Reneveys Rind
ist seit zwei Tagen unruhig.
Er meint, es würde bereits kalben,
weil es blute,
aber es geht nicht weiter.
Wenn wir das Kalb und die Mutter
retten wollen,
müssen wir sofort etwas tun.
Éléonore und ihre Assistentin Déborah
bereiten alles für den Eingriff vor.
Der Bauer versucht inzwischen,
Violette zu beruhigen.
Beruhig dich!
Als wir ihr vorgestern Abend
eine Spritze geben wollten,
tobte und stampfte sie so sehr,
dass wir der Meinung waren,
dass es unmöglich ist.
(Beruhigend) Hallo, Schätzchen.
- Hey, hey.
Ruhig, Schätzchen, ganz ruhig.
- Hey, hey, hey. Ruhig, ruhig.
Darf ich dir eine Spritze geben?
- Zur Betäubung?
Um den Geburtsweg zu dehnen.
Wir dehnen ihn.
Du bist ein Lausemädchen.
Wir helfen dir ein bisschen. Beim
ersten Mal ist es immer schwierig.
Éléonore hofft, mit dieser Spritze
die Gebärmutter dehnen zu können.
Violette ist erst zweieinhalb Jahre
alt und kalbt zum ersten Mal.
Das kann manchmal heikel sein.
Es besteht immer ein Risiko,
z.B., wenn das Kalb zu gross ist
oder das Rind
die Geburt nicht alleine schafft.
Beim ersten Abkalben
sind die Geburtswege sehr eng.
Das Fruchtwasser ging bereits ab.
Darum muss man das Kalb
rasch rausholen.
Aber auch wenn es eilt, darf Éléonore
keine hektische Bewegung machen.
Also, meine Liebe ...
Könntest du kurz wegschauen?
* Sie macht beruhigende Geräusche. *
Also ...
So. Ruhig, meine Liebe.
Ganz ruhig, ruhig.
Ruhig.
- He, he.
Hoppla.
Beruhig dich!
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Geht's?
- Es treibt noch nicht aus.
Die Klauen und den Kopf spüre ich.
Sie sind jedoch ganz weit hinten.
Nun muss alles
durchs Becken hindurch.
Wenn sie nicht genügend presst,
wird es schwierig.
Das Kalb liegt falsch.
- Es lebt.
Es ist also noch nicht zu spät,
um zu versuchen, das Kalb zu retten.
Déborah bringt zwei Seile,
die um die Klauen gewickelt werden.
Blau links und rot rechts.
- Kannst du mir das Seil geben?
Das ist nichts Schlimmes.
Sie arbeitet schon, aber wir
versuchen sie nun zu unterstützen.
Ich muss das Kalb
in die richtige Position bringen
und den Kopf durchs Becken ziehen.
Es kann sein,
dass es zu gross für das Becken ist.
Aber ein weiteres Problem ist,
dass das Rind nicht ruhig ist.
Bei diesem Eingriff sind
sehr viel Geduld und Zeit nötig.
Sie will mir
jedoch keine Zeit lassen.
* Éléonore stöhnt frustriert. *
Hey, hey, hey!
Obwohl man es ihm nicht ansieht:
Gabriel ist innerlich
total angespannt.
Hey, hey, hey.
Wenn ein Rind so unruhig ist
und ständig herumspringt,
kann man nichts mehr tun.
Éléonore muss sich entscheiden.
Bitte?
- Wir müssen sie beruhigen.
Ein Beruhigungsmittel? Mir wäre es
lieber, sie würde pressen.
Es gibt keine gute Lösung.
Wenn ich sie nicht sediere,
schlägt sie aus
und ich kann nicht arbeiten.
Wenn ich es tue, presst sie nicht.
Können Sie mal an der Klaue ziehen?
Was muss ich tun?
- An der Klaue ziehen.
Möglichst sanft.
- Éléonore braucht Verstärkung.
Vielleicht
kann der Vater des Besitzers helfen.
Also, meine Liebe.
* Sie stöhnt angestrengt. *
Komm raus!
Die Zeit drängt.
Ich sehe und spüre es und es lebt,
aber vielleicht nicht mehr lange.
Ich befürchte, dass es stirbt,
dass der Kopf zur Seite fällt.
Wir müssen etwas nachhelfen.
* Sie stöhnt angestrengt. *
Ja.
(Beruhigend) Ich weiss, ich weiss.
Ich kann froh sein,
dass sie nicht ausschlägt.
Wenn sie plötzlich herumspringt,
kann man sich rasch den Arm brechen.
Nein!
Okay, wir sedieren sie ein wenig,
sonst wird das nichts.
Éléonore verliert langsam die Geduld.
Mit dieser Spritze
soll sich das Rind beruhigen.
Aber Gabriel
ist sich nicht mehr sicher,
ob man nicht doch besser
einen Kaiserschnitt wagen sollte.
Ein Kaiserschnitt ist teuer,
aber wenigstens habe ich dann
ein lebendes Kalb.
Dann bleibt es meist am Leben.
Die Zeit wird knapp
und die Spannung steigt.
Für einen Kaiserschnitt
muss ich Verstärkung holen.
Einen Kaiserschnitt macht man nur,
wenn sonst gar nichts mehr geht.
Gabriel ist unsicher.
Und wenn wir sie
dort hinten blockieren würden?
Das wäre mir recht. Dann könnten wir
wenigstens 5 Min. in Ruhe arbeiten.
Gut, wir machen es so.
Für die Operation müssten wir sie
ja auch ruhigstellen.
Aber die Kuh ruhigzustellen,
ist ein ziemliches Theater.
Nein, aber hallo!
(Beruhigend) Hey, hey, hey. Voilà,
jetzt schliessen wir das Tor.
(Beruhigend) Ja, ja, ja.
Ich dachte, wir würden die Kuh
nie zum Kalben ins Gehege kriegen.
Ich überlegte mir,
wie wir sie beruhigen könnten.
So, nun kann sie
nicht mehr ausschlagen.
Langsam!
Sie müssen ziehen, damit ich schauen
kann, ob der Kopf durchkommt.
* Sie ächzt. *
Nein.
Er kommt durch,
aber du musst uns unterstützen. So.
Der Kopf ist schon mal
an der richtigen Stelle.
Debi, etwas Gleitgel
auf meinen Arm bitte.
Super, danke.
Also, komm jetzt.
* Sie ächzt. *
Nein.
* Ächzen *
Okay.
Gibst du mir bitte
den Geburtshelfer?
Mit dem Geburtshelfer sollte man
das Kalb herausziehen können.
Ich versuchte,
mit dem Geburtshelfer an den Klauen
und gleichzeitig am Kopf zu ziehen.
Es wäre schön,
wenn es klappen würde.
Aber dann dachte ich: "Den Kopf
kriege ich vielleicht noch durch,
aber was tue ich,
wenn der Rumpf stecken bleibt?"
Nein, das geht nicht.
Okay.
Wird der Brustkorb des Kalbs
im Becken eingeklemmt,
geht nichts mehr.
Geht es nicht?
- Nein, es geht nicht.
Das Kalb ist zu gross und kann
nicht natürlich zur Welt kommen.
Willst du den Kaiserschnitt
gleich hier machen?- Ja.
* Seufzen *
Kaiserschnitt bei so einer Kuh.
Sie steht sogar noch falsch.
Ja, hallo?
- Alix, hörst du mich?
Ja.- Könntest du mir
Jean-François schicken?
Jean-François? Wieso?
Wir müssen sie aufschneiden. Aber
die Kuh ist ziemlich unkooperativ.
Okay, ich hole Jean-François.
Sag mir noch, was genau los ist.
Er soll sofort losfahren.
Das Kalb lebt noch.
Okay, ich sage ihm,
dass es ein Notfall ist.
Ja, danke, so rasch wie möglich.
Okay, ciao.
- Ciao.
Éléonore verlor wegen der
aufgeregten Kuh eine halbe Stunde.
Wie soll man ohne an sie heran-
zukommen einen Kaiserschnitt machen?
Tücher und eine Schermaschine
holt der Bauer.
Wir öffnen sie
hier auf der linken Seite.
Éléonore wartet auf Verstärkung ...
... und im Tierspital in Bern
steht eine riesige Dogge am Empfang:
Ioda.
- Hier ist das Formular.
Dort drüben?
- Ja.
Melanie hat den gutmütigen Riesen
seit sechs Jahren
und er gehorcht ihr aufs Wort.
Sitz. Komm, sitz. Sitz.
Sitz, sitz.
Sie macht sich grosse Sorgen.
Er hat ein Geschwür am Ellbogen,
das ganz plötzlich auftrat.
Unsere Nachbarin ist Tierärztin
und hat ihm am Freitag
Blut abgenommen.
Bei der Blutuntersuchung
zeigte sich,
dass Ioda
extrem hohe Nierenwerte hat.
Bei achtfach erhöhten Nierenwerten
muss man ans Schlimmste denken.
Mir wurde gesagt, dass man bei
solchen Werten nichts mehr tun kann.
Die ganze Familie
ist völlig vor den Kopf gestossen.
Ioda ist eine Art Maskottchen für sie
und nun soll er nur noch
ein paar Monate leben können?
Der Hund will nicht mit.
Er wurde schon mehrmals
am Ellbogen operiert.
Darum hat er etwas gegen Tierärzte.
Soll ich Sie nach hinten begleiten?
- Mhm.
Komm, Schatz.
Er ist ein Schmusehund
und will immer gestreichelt werden.
Komm, auf!
- Komm, komm, komm.
Komm, komm, komm.
Ja.
Unsere drei Kinder sagen,
er sei ihr bester Freund.
Gleich hier rein.
Wir sind ein Herz und eine Seele.
Hallo, Ioda, hallo.
So, mal sehen.
Eins, zwei, drei. Steh auf!
Komm! Oh, er ist total gestresst.
Hei, ei, ei.
Alix untersucht das Geschwür
an Iodas Ellbogen.
Aber eigentlich
müsste man zuerst herausfinden,
was mit den Nieren des Hundes
los ist.
Die Blutanalyse und Iodas Zustand
passen nicht zusammen.
Man befürchtet natürlich,
dass es etwas sein könnte,
das man von aussen nicht sieht,
z.B. etwas Krebsartiges.
Es könnte schwierig werden,
hier etwas zu finden.
Er ist noch jung
und es wäre furchtbar,
das seiner Besitzerin
sagen zu müssen.
Dann schickt Alix
die Blutprobe ins Labor.
Es ist alles gut, Grosser. Tipptopp.
Ich frage mich dauernd,
ob ich etwas hätte bemerken müssen.
Vielleicht habe ich etwas übersehen,
aber er hat keine Symptome.
Bei diesen Blutwerten
müsste er erbrechen,
keinen Appetit haben
und sehr viel trinken.
Ioda trottet seelenruhig
durch den Gang.
Das macht Alix stutzig.
Okay, versuch mal,
mit ihm zu rennen.
Also, komm. Hopp, hopp, hopp!
Mit so hohen Nierenwerten müsste es
ihm eigentlich total schlecht gehen.
Schlecht scheint es ihm
aber gar nicht zu gehen.
Er will sogar gestreichelt werden.
- Du bist ein Lieber, was?
Zum Glück ist er so lieb.
Er versteckt sich auch gern
zwischen den Beinen der Leute.
Man könnte fast denken, er würde
bei den Menschen Schutz suchen.
Er hat kein Fieber
und auch keine Anzeichen
irgendwelcher Entzündungen.
Alix hat richtig Spass
an ihrem Teddybären.
Warum bist du denn so gestresst?
- Das ist der Urin fürs Labor.
Ich dachte, das sei Honig.
* Beide lachen. *
Alix müsste
mit der Besitzerin sprechen,
aber sie bleibt noch etwas bei Ioda,
um ihn zu beruhigen.
Hey, du bist so gestresst.
Ja, du lieber Grosser.
(Beruhigend) Ja.
Nur gestresste Hunde heute, was?
Zu uns kommen viele Deutsche Doggen.
Sie sind wie grosse Teddybären.
Sie haben ein gutes Gemüt.
Sie sind total lieb und anhänglich.
Barbarino. Guten Tag.
Bleiben Sie nur sitzen.
Es dauerte etwas,
weil wir uns Ioda und die Blutwerte
genau anschauten.
Iodas Besitzerin macht sich
wegen der Blutwerte grosse Sorgen.
Sie ist auf das Schlimmste gefasst.
Es scheint uns seltsam,
dass er bei diesen hohen Werten
keine klinischen Anzeichen aufwies.
Kein Aufstossen, keinen Durchfall.
- Nein.
Das macht uns stutzig,
weil die Nierenwerte sehr hoch sind.
Er ist extrem belastbar.
Als er am Ellbogen operiert wurde,
machte er keinen Mucks,
obwohl der Arzt ohne Betäubung
mit dem Skalpell
an ihm herumschnippelte.
Ohne Anästhesie?
- Nein.
Dieser Hund
zeigt keine Anzeichen von Schmerzen.
Man weiss nicht, ob es ihm wehtut.
Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher,
ob er überhaupt Schmerz empfindet.
Darum sieht man ihm auch nicht an,
ob er etwas hat.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall einen
Schritt nach dem anderen machen.
Der nächste Schritt
ist eine neue Blutuntersuchung.
Alix will noch andere Blutwerte
analysieren und Melanie hofft weiter.
Okay, vielen Dank.
- Danke.
Ans Schlimmste
will ich gar nicht denken.
Ich glaube, er braucht unsere Nähe
und unsere positiven Gefühle.
Aus diesem Grund versuche ich,
positiv zu denken.
Bis Iodas Ergebnisse eintreffen,
kümmert sich Alix
um einen neuen Notfall.
Popcorn war kurz vor dem Ersticken
und kann nur noch
durch eine Kanüle atmen,
die ihr der Tierarzt
in die Luftröhre steckte.
Als Popcorn eingeliefert wurde,
war sie betäubt.
Ihr Tierarzt musste die Luftröhre
perforieren, damit sie atmen konnte.
Die oberen Luftwege sind verstopft
und eine Öffnung weiter unten
ist die einzige Option,
um Luft hereinzulassen.
Rechts ist es stärker geschwollen
als links.
(Mann) Ja, die zwei Seiten
sind schon ...- Ja.
... extrem entzündet.
Der Chefarzt für Innere Medizin
und Alix stellen fest,
dass der Rachen
stark geschwollen ist.
Alix legt die Katze sorgfältig in die
Sauerstoffbox der Intensivstation,
bevor sie zu den Besitzerinnen geht.
Hallo.
Die Kanüle darf sich nicht bewegen,
sonst erstickt Popcorn.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Guten Tag. Barbarino,
ich bin die Tierärztin.
Können Sie mir kurz erklären,
was mit Popcorn passierte?
Hier steht,
dass es vor zwei Tagen anfing.
Am Samstagmorgen.
- Okay. Wie fing es an?
Als ich nachschaute, lag sie
vor unserer Thuja-Hecke am Boden.
Sie war nicht verletzt,
konnte jedoch nicht mehr atmen.
Ich dachte sofort an einen Unfall,
weil sie so seltsam am Boden lag.
Wir sahen, dass der Rachen
stark geschwollen ist.
Laëtitias Tochter hört ganz genau zu.
Laly bekam Popcorn
vor vier Jahren zum Geburtstag.
Alix ist ihre letzte Hoffnung.
(Alix) Wir beobachten sie
einfach weiterhin.
Laëtitia ist es wichtig,
dass es ihren Tieren gut geht
und dass sie nicht leiden.
Popcorn mit einem Schlauch im Hals
kann sie sich nicht vorstellen.
Wenn sie ohne Kanüle leben kann,
ist es okay,
aber künstliche
Lebensverlängerung ...
So muss wieder so leben können wie
früher, sonst hat es keinen Sinn.
Sie will doch jagen,
aufs Dach klettern ...
Ja, das kann sie jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay, dann schreibe ich hier:
"Wiederbelebung negativ."
So ist es für alle klar.
Ja.- Bei "Beatmung"
schreibe ich "okay".
Nein.
Ich möchte noch mit ihr reden.
- Okay.
Gut, vielen Dank.
- Ich danke Ihnen.
In der Inneren Medizin wird alles
für eine Endoskopie vorbereitet.
Popcorn ist eingeschlafen.
Mit einer Minikamera
wollen die Ärzt:innen sehen,
was mit dem Rachen los ist.
(Alix) Ganz vorsichtig.
- Ja, da sieht man die Röhre.
Ist es eine Tumormasse, ein Abszess
oder eine starke Entzündung?
Ein kleiner Bienenstachel z.B.
Oder sie hat etwas gefressen,
das hängen geblieben ist.
Das könnten alles Gründe für eine
Schwellung im Hals oder Rachen sein.
Auf dem Bildschirm sieht man jetzt
das Innere des Halses.
Dort, es kommt raus.
- Hier ist es.
An einem Ort
ist die Luftröhre so geschwollen,
dass man nicht durchkommt.
Aber man sieht weder einen Tumor
noch Fremdkörper.
(Alix)
Jetzt sieht man gleich die Kanüle.
* Piepsen
eines medizinischen Geräts *
Die Beatmungskanüle
ist immer noch gut platziert.
(Chefarzt) Wir werden
den Besitzern vorschlagen,
uns etwas Zeit zu geben,
bevor wir die Kanüle entfernen.
Ja, das wäre mir auch lieber.
Zu mir sagte sie,
sie wolle nicht weitermachen.
Andererseits meinte sie, wenn es
nur ein spitzer Gegenstand war
und sie sich wieder erholen würde,
sollten wir es versuchen.
Ich glaube,
wir haben noch eine Chance,
sie zu überzeugen,
noch nicht aufzugeben.
Zurzeit haben wir
nur eine starke Entzündung.- Ja.
Wir müssen der Katze
noch etwas Zeit lassen.
Eine definitive Entscheidung
ist nie zu spät, höchstens zu früh.
Hoffentlich geben die Besitzerinnen
Popcorn noch eine Chance und warten,
bis man sieht, ob die
entzündungshemmenden Mittel wirken.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Alix ist wieder bei Ioda.
Die Deutsche Dogge
scheint schwer nierenkrank zu sein.
Die Blutprobe ist noch im Labor.
Jetzt kann Alix die Wunde am Ellbogen
mal genauer betrachten.
Bei grossen Hunden kann es
zu solchen Liegeschwielen kommen,
weil sie mit ihrem ganzen Gewicht
auf dem Ellbogen liegen.
Alix schaut,
ob eine Infektion vorhanden ist.
Ioda macht keinen Mucks.
(Beruhigend) Oh, ja, ja, ja.
Er ist wirklich
extrem schmerzunempfindlich.
* Handy *
Das ist die Chefin
der Notfallstation.
Hier ist Karin für Alix.
(Übers Handy) Hier ist Katja.
Iodas Nierenwerte sind total normal.
Okay.
- Okay.
Wahrscheinlich
wurden die Proben verwechselt.
Es ist also alles in Ordnung,
habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja, alle Werte sind normal.
- Ja, das war ein Fehler des Labors.
Wir sprechen von Iodas Probe, oder?
- Mhm.
Ja, das war die einzige,
die wir bekamen.
Okay, dann stimmt ja alles.
Sollen wir noch
eine Kontrolle raufschicken?
Ja, genau, super.
Danke für den Anruf.
Ich danke dir.
- Tipptopp, danke.
Zur Sicherheit müssen wir es
nochmals kontrollieren.
Wenn das erste Labor einen Fehler
gemacht hat und Ioda gesund ist,
wäre das eine tolle Nachricht
Wenn er krank wäre und wir behaupten
würden, dass er gesund sei,
wäre es schlimmer.
Darum: Doppelt genäht hält besser.
Auch der zweite Labortest ist gut.
Alix kann mit gutem Gewissen
die Besitzerin anrufen.
Ich möchte Ihnen mitteilen,
wie es um Ioda steht.
Ich habe gute Neuigkeiten.
- Ach ja?
Ah, super.
- Es liegt kein Nierenversagen vor.
Wahrscheinlich wurden die Blutproben
verwechselt. Das kommt vor.
Wir müssen unbedingt herausfinden,
von welchem Patienten
diese Werte sind.
Es ist wichtig,
dem Besitzer Bescheid zu geben.
Aber wir können Iodas Austritt
schon für heute Nachmittag planen.
Ah, super. Vielen Dank.
Ich werde dabei sein,
wenn Sie ihn abholen.
Sehr schön. Bis bald.
So, du. Nun willst du
schon wieder nach Hause, was?
Oh, was mache ich nur ohne dich?
Hey, hoppla. Oh, hey.
Warten.
Das ist wirklich ein Lichtblick. So
schöne Überraschungen sind selten.
Oft geht es dem Tier gut,
aber die Laborwerte sind schlecht.
Na, wohin gehen wir?
Wohin gehen wir?
Wo ist sie denn?
- Hallo.
Hallo, Grosser.
* Lachen *
Ups.
Oh.
Na, du. Hallo, Grosser.
Hallo, du Lieber.
- Du bist so zufrieden, was?
* Lachen *
Manchmal stellt er sich neben einen,
als wolle er sagen: "Setz dich hin."
Die Frage ist, wer zuerst hinfällt.
Ich, weil er weggeht,
oder er, weil ich aufstehe.
Das war unser Zeitvertreib.
Er ist ein Schatz.
Ja.
- Er ist so lieb.
Ja. -Du sitzt auf meinem Fuss.
Willst du ihn ausbrüten?
Ich bin natürlich glücklich,
aber auch verärgert.
Wir haben ein ganz schlimmes
Wochenende hinter uns.
Wir dachten, er werde sterben.
Das ist der beste Befund des Tages.
So gute Nachrichten sind selten.
Darum freuen wir uns
fast so sehr wie Sie.
Ich hoffe sehr, dass das Labor
die Besitzer des Tiers findet,
zu dem die Blutwerte gehören,
und wünsche ihm das Beste.
Du musst von meinem Fuss runter.
- Komm.
* Lachen *
Komm her.
Kommen Sie gut nach Hause. Hoffent-
lich sehen wir uns nicht mehr.- Ja.
So, das ist gut, was?
* Kussgeräusch *
Komm.
Wir gehen nach Hause.
Endlich darf Ioda wieder nach Hause.
Seine Familie kann es kaum erwarten.
In Fétigny/FR
wartet Éléonore auf Verstärkung.
Es ist alles bereit
für den Kaiserschnitt,
nur die Kuh muss umplatziert werden.
Sie ist furchtbar unruhig.
- Sie haben sie falsch gestellt.
Ich weiss nicht, was Sie vorhaben.
Wir müssen sie
mit dem Gatter zurückstossen,
sonst lässt sie mich nicht ran.
* Muhen *
He, he, he.
* Er seufzt frustriert. *
So geht's nicht, Schätzchen.
Violette scheint ein Problem
mit der Tierärztin zu haben.
Éléonore muss
aus ihrem Blickfeld verschwinden.
Oh!
Voilà, ich bin das Problem.
He!
Als ich mit ihr allein war,
beruhigte sie sich ein wenig.
Aber sobald sie jemand anderen sah,
führte sie sich wieder wie wild auf.
Ich dachte, sie würde jeden Moment
über den Zaun springen.
Endlich ist sie unter Kontrolle.
Éléonore ist froh, dass ihr
ihr Kollege zu Hilfe kommt.
Das ist sie?
- Ich komme gleich. Sie ...
Du siehst es dann ja.
- Kein Problem.
Der Belgier Jean-François
hat Erfahrung mit Kaiserschnitten.
Die belgischen Kühe
tragen extrem grosse Kälber,
darum ist ein Kaiserschnitt
für ihn an der Tagesordnung.
Ist es so okay?
- Noch etwas weiter runter.
Falls sie sich hinlegt,
kann es noch tiefer sein.
* Geräusch der Schermaschine *
Sei vorsichtig.
- Geht es kaputt?
Nein, aber ...
Deswegen.
- Komm, komm, komm.
Der Bauer stellt notfallmässig
einen Operationstisch auf.
Es kann losgehen.
Als Erstes eine Lokalnarkose.
- Ist schon alles bereit?- Ja.
Jemand muss ihren Schwanz halten.
Oder auch nicht.
- Das geht schon.
Hoppla-hopp.
Nun muss Jean-François
an die Kuh rankommen,
damit er sie operieren kann.
Wir schliessen das Tor.
- Ja, das ist klüger.
Ja, mach es doch
durchs Tor hindurch.
Wenn Gabriel die Kuh streichelt,
wirkt die Narkose am besten.
Die linke Flanke ist offen.
Gabriel ist nicht mehr ganz sicher,
ob er richtig entschieden hat.
Ein Kaiserschnitt ist teuer
und wenn das Kalb tot ist,
hat er einen riesigen Verlust.
Éléonore ist seit über einer Stunde
hier und auch sie hat ihre Zweifel.
Ich dachte, es sei zu spät.
Wir verloren viel Zeit,
bis das Rind stillstand.
Es sprang so wild herum,
dass ich dachte,
das Kalb sei schon lange tot.
Ich dachte, es sei erstickt.
Jean-François steckt
mit beiden Armen in Violettes Bauch.
Wenn das Tier jetzt hinfällt,
stirbt es.
Nun ist Éléonore dran.
Sie muss mit dem Skalpell
die Gebärmutter aufschneiden.
Hast du es?
- Ja.
Ziehen, ziehen, ziehen!
Noch etwas mehr! Ich schreie schon,
wenn du mir in die Hand schneidest.
Noch etwas mehr!
- Vorher schneide ich in meine.
Weiter komme ich nicht.
- So.
Jetzt muss es schnell gehen.
Éléonore
durchtrennte die Nabelschnur.
Das Kalb bekommt keinen Sauerstoff
mehr und muss umgehend raus.
Jede Sekunde zählt.
* Alle ächzen angestrengt. *
Zu mir drehen! Zu mir drehen!
Weiter runter. Runter, runter!
Wir müssen es runterdrücken.
Oh, Mist. Ziehen Sie von unten!
Gut. Das ist gut so.
Ziehen!
Es kommt.
- Es ist okay.
Es kommt, ja.
Noch ein wenig, noch ein wenig!
Einen Moment, die Nabelschnur.
Gut. Jetzt ziehen, ziehen!
Noch ein wenig!
Als es rauskam,
bewegte es sich praktisch nicht.
Ich dachte, es sei tot.
Kaltes Wasser. Leeren Sie ihm
kaltes Wasser über den Kopf!
Dann bewegte sich das Ohr ...
- Einen Schlauch, schnell!
... und ich hatte wieder Hoffnung.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass sie es wiederbeleben können.
Es war viel kaltes Wasser
und Herzstimulation nötig.
Es sieht etwas brutal aus,
aber nur dank dieser Wieder-
belebungsversuche lebt es noch.
Das Kälbchen lebt.
Éléonore hatte recht: ein Maxibaby.
Ich glaube,
es wiegt bestimmt 50-60 kg.
Ein gesundes Kalb
wiegt in der Regel 30-40 kg.
Für die Mutter
ist es oft nicht die erste Geburt,
aber für Violette schon.
Das Kalb ist sehr gross.
Nun noch zunähen. Das machen
Éléonore und Jean-François gemeinsam.
Wenn ich es schnell gemacht hätte,
wäre es mir nicht gelungen.- Klar.
* Lachen *
Alle sind erleichtert
nach dieser grossen Anspannung.
Stell dir vor, du machst den Kaiser-
schnitt und es beginnt zu regnen.
* Lachen *
Das Wetter schlägt um und das
Kälbchen wird in den Stall gebracht.
Dort kümmert sich
eine andere Kuh um es.
In einer Stunde
ist es auf den Beinen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Leck es schön sauber!
Es antwortet niemand?
Wir haben eine Notfallnummer.
Sie müssen sich die Nachricht
bis zum Schluss anhören.
Dann hören Sie es.
In der Mittagspause müsste Éléonore
Notanrufe entgegennehmen.
Einige Katzen auf einem
anderen Bauernhof sind krank.
Sie müssen mich entschuldigen.
Ich bin gerade sehr beschäftigt.
Danke. Auf Wiederhören.
Die Leute wissen nicht, in welchen
Situationen wir uns teils befinden.
Dann kommen sie einfach
ins Plaudern.- Genau.
* Lachen *
Bis die Gebärmutter
und die Muskeln vernäht sind,
vergeht nochmals eine Stunde.
Die Naht muss halten, damit Violette
nächstes Jahr wieder kalben kann.
Die Operation ist zu Ende
und Gabriel gratuliert seiner Kuh.
Gut gemacht.
- Debi, nun bist du dran.
Und nun noch gut desinfizieren.
Ich will keinen Tropfen Blut
mehr sehen.
Sieh mal!
* Lachen *
Ah, ein Herz.
Ah!
Was ist?
Etwas Fantasie tut dieser Welt gut.
* Debi lacht. *
Endlich darf Violette zu ihrem Kalb.
Wunderbar.
Éléonore ist froh,
dass alles gut ging.
Ja, das ist deins.
Das ist deins.
Das war schon eine Herausforderung.
Man steht total unter Druck.
Aber wenn alles gut geht,
ist man überglücklich,
weil die Operation gelungen ist,
aber v.a., weil das Kälbchen lebt.
Es ist ein harter Job, klar,
aber es lohnt sich.
Mit dem Herz auf dem Hintern.
Es ist schon bald 14 Uhr.
- Zeit fürs Mittagessen.
In 30 Min.
ist unsere Mittagspause vorbei.
Mit leerem Magen,
blauen Flecken und Blut im Gesicht
verlässt Éléonore den Bauernhof.
Hoffentlich gerate ich nicht
in eine Polizeikontrolle.
Die würden sich wundern.
- Du bist doch Tierärztin.
Ja, ich habe eine gute Ausrede.
Das werde ich
nicht so schnell vergessen.
Das war Rodeo.
Éléonore fährt zurück
in ihre Praxis ...
... und in Florences Wartesaal
in Corcelles-près-Payerne
tigern einige Patienten
ungeduldig umher.
* Knurren, aufgeregtes Hecheln *
* Drollige Klänge *
Komm, Gibson.
- Nun ist Gibson an der Reihe.
Er ist ziemlich angeschlagen.
(Florence) Wie? 40 kg?
- Ja?
So schwer?
Siehst du, es ist ihm peinlich.
Seit drei Tagen
frisst Gibson nichts mehr
und kann sich kaum mehr
auf den Beinen halten.
Nach 50 m
wollte er bereits umkehren.
Also, komm, Gibson,
schön raufklettern!
Er ist mit seinen 14 Jahren
zwar nicht mehr der Jüngste,
aber so schlapp ist er sonst nicht.
Gibson hat hohes Fieber.
Das macht Meyli am meisten Angst.
Er hat irgendein Geschwulst
in der Nähe der Lippe.
Zuerst dachte ich, er sei
von einem Insekt gestochen worden,
aber es wurde jeden Tag schlimmer.
Oje, oje, oje.
Ja.
- Komm!
Komm! So. So.
Komm!
- Lass ihn doch so.
So, jetzt, jetzt. Ja.
So ist es gut. Ja.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui, ui.
- Er kratzt sich dauernd.
Das ist eine Infektion -
nahe beim Auge.
Es sah schlimm aus.
Die Entzündung war sehr unsauber
und reichte fast ganz bis zum Auge.
Heute Morgen konnte er das Auge
fast nicht mehr öffnen.
Ich dachte nicht,
dass es so schlimm ist.
Du klangst nicht so verzweifelt.
Es sah erst gestern Abend
schlimmer aus.
Eitert es sogar?
- Ja.
Du bist ein Lieber, gell?
Wir rasieren den ganzen Bereich.
Ganz ruhig.
Gibson leidet.
Das juckt ihn sicher wahnsinnig.
Es ist ganz in der Nähe des Auges,
siehst du?
Meyli macht sich Sorgen um ihren
Hund, der auch ihr Vertrauter ist.
Der Hund ist wahnsinnig tapfer.
Er ist einzigartig.
Einem Hund erzählt man Dinge,
die man Menschen nie erzählen würde:
ein Trauerfall in der Familie,
Probleme mit den Kindern usw.
Jeder braucht jemanden,
dem er alles anvertrauen kann.
Ich habe Gibson.
Er schweigt.
Er muss etwas erwischt haben,
auf das er allergisch ist.
Aber was das sein könnte,
wissen wir nicht.
Er hatte sicher Kontakt
mit einer Pflanze oder so,
auf die er allergisch ist.
Das löste die Infektion aus.
Wenn der Hund in der Natur
etwas berührt,
kann es rasch
zu einer Kontaktallergie kommen.
Es juckt wie verrückt
und er kratzt sich,
bis es zu einer Infektion kommt.
Das nennt man auch Hotspot,
weil die Wunde rot und rund ist.
Er ist nicht ganz sauber rasiert,
aber so sieht es besser aus.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Und hier ... Oje.
- Meinst du, das reicht?
Hier unten geht es gleich weiter.
Die Infektion ist viel weiter
fortgeschritten als gedacht.
Ich wüsste nicht, was ich noch
rasieren sollte. Es ist alles weg.
Siehst du? Es ist alles entzündet.
Wenn wir nichts tun, kann sich das
auf den ganzen Körper ausweiten
und könnte an anderen Orten
noch weitere Entzündungen auslösen.
Die Infektion
könnte so schlimm werden,
dass Gibson
sogar daran sterben könnte.
Ganz ruhig. Ja, das tut weh.
Florence reinigt die Wunde
mit einem desinfizierenden Shampoo.
Zum Glück seid ihr gekommen.
Meyli liebt alle Tiere auf ihrem Hof,
aber sie hat auch ihre Prinzipien.
Ich wuchs auf einem Bauernhof auf.
Darum habe ich
einen anderen Bezug zum Tier
als eine alte Dame zu
ihrem Chihuahua, der nur rumliegt.
Wenn bei uns auf dem Hof ein Tier
starb, sagte mein Vater jeweils:
"Es ist besser, wenn eins
im Stall fehlt als in der Küche."
So wurde ich erzogen.
Daher: Obwohl ich den Hund gernhabe,
wenn Florence mir gesagt hätte,
dass es ganz schlimm ist,
z.B. wegen Krebs oder so,
hätte ich ihn einschläfern lassen.
Zum Glück ist es bei Gibson
noch nicht so schlimm.
Voilà, so, schön. Ah, warte kurz!
Aber langsam wird er unruhig.
Ja, schön. Das ist doch nur Honig.
Mit Mühe gelingt es ihr, die Wunde
mit einer Honigcreme einzuschmieren.
Ja, schön.
- Jetzt ist es gut.
Das geht schon.
Honig? Richtiger Honig? Hilft das?
Ja.
- Tatsächlich?- Klar.
Komm jetzt, Gibson!
* Gibson knurrt. *
Oh, du bist gestresst, was?
- Honig aus der Region hätte ich.
Gut hast du das gemacht.
Nun gibt's eine Belohnung.
Damit du das Ganze vergisst.
Möchtest du?
Meylis Mann
findet den Hund etwas zu dick.
Darum würde er ihm
lieber nichts geben.
Das reicht. Okay.
Er ist schon 5 kg zu schwer.
Aber heute hat er
noch nichts gefressen, oder?- Doch.
Wie schwer müsste er denn sein?
Er ist schon etwas mollig,
aber in diesem Alter muss er
nicht mehr abnehmen.- Genau.
Er soll so leben, wie er ist.
Ansonsten hätte ich gesagt,
dass er 5 kg zu schwer ist.
Aber in seinem Alter
lassen wir ihn sein Leben leben.
5 kg - so wie ich.
* Florence lacht. *
Ich lebe mein Leben.
Ein richtiges Kunstwerk.
- Das finde ich auch.
Also, mein Schatz, tschüss.
Wenn es in zwei Tagen nicht
besser ist, rufst du nochmals an.
Meyli ist froh,
dass sie ihrem Hund weiterhin
ihre Sorgen anvertrauen kann.
Nach einigen Tagen mit Antibiotika
sollte er fit genug sein,
um ihr wieder zuzuhören.
Im Tierspital in Bern
sieht Alix nach Popcorn.
Hallo, du. Hey, wie geht's?
Na? Hallo.
Oh, ja? Hallo.
Seit fünf Tagen atmet sie schon
durch die Kanüle in der Luftröhre.
Hallo.
* Schnurren *
Hey, du schnurrst ja
durchs Röhrchen.
Popcorn ist zum Liebling
der Intensivstation geworden.
Sie ist extrem anhänglich
und würde uns am liebsten
auf die Schultern springen.
Daher müssen wir sie
leider immer etwas zurückhalten.
Sie ist wirklich süss.
Die Besitzerinnen sahen ihre Katze
seit der Einlieferung nicht mehr
und denken, dass ihre Katze
mit dem Röhrchen im Hals sehr leidet.
Diesen Zustand
wollen sie nicht unnötig verlängern.
Wir wollten, dass sie wieder
wie eine normale Katze leben kann.
Ich möchte sicher sein,
dass sie nicht leidet.
Oh, wenn nur dein Rachen
abschwellen würde.
Ich sagte: "Wenn bis am Mittwoch
keine klare Besserung eintritt ..."
Ich will ja nicht darauf beharren,
sie am leben zu erhalten -
nach fünf Tagen.
Die fünf Tage sind um,
aber Alix will mehr Zeit rausholen.
Wir können diese Katze
nicht einschläfern.
Das geht doch nicht, Fräulein.
- Ihr Entschluss steht fest:
Alix will es darauf ankommen lassen
und die Kanüle entfernen,
obwohl der Rachen
noch nicht ganz abgeschwollen ist.
Es ist ungewiss, ob Popcorn
dann trotzdem noch atmen kann.
Der Chefarzt ist zurückhaltend.
Warum speichelt die Katze so? Bekam
sie ein Beruhigungsmittel?- Nein.
Es begann vor 30 Min. Als sich
die Kanüle verschob, sabberte sie.
Wegen des Stresses.
Die Ärzt:innen wollen Popcorn
noch eine Chance geben
und sind bereit, alles zu versuchen.
Wollen wir es versuchen?
- Ich würde sagen, ja.
Kein leichter Entscheid.
Wir standen stark unter Druck.
Die Verletzung im Rachen
sah schon besser aus,
aber niemand konnte sagen,
ob die Katze ohne die Trachealkanüle
selbstständig würde atmen können.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ready?- Vielleicht sollten wir
übers Brustbein rein.
Dann kriegt sie mehr Luft.
Nein.- Aber danach
ist eine grössere Naht nötig.
Zögere es nicht länger hinaus.
Wenn es nicht funktioniert hätte,
hätten wir wieder
eine Kanüle einpflanzen müssen.
Aus Liebe zum Tier
wäre die Besitzerin dagegen gewesen.
Das wäre wohl
Popcorns Todesurteil gewesen.
Let's get it out.
Die Beatmungskanüle ist draussen.
Alle hören angespannt auf Popcorn.
Kann sie selbst atmen oder nicht?
Ah, sie atmet.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Die Erleichterung ist gross.
Popcorn atmet selbstständig,
obwohl sie noch etwas verwirrt ist.
Sie wacht langsam auf.
- Die Atmung ist perfekt.
Alix hatte recht.
Nun muss sie Popcorn
aber noch ganz genau beobachten.
So, nun kommst du hier rein.
Ja.
Nun kommt das Interessante auf der
Intensivstation: die Überwachung.
Man sitzt vor dem Tier
und beobachtet es ganz genau -
in der Hoffnung,
dass alles gut geht.
Das kann ein paar Minuten
oder auch ein paar Tage dauern.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Weshalb Popcorn nicht mehr atmen
konnte, wird man nie herausfinden.
Vielleicht
verschluckte sie eine Wespe.
Aber die Hauptsache ist,
dass es ihr wieder gut geht.
Ein kleines Wunder.
Als sie uns sagten,
dass wir sie abholen können,
freuten wir uns wahnsinnig.
Meine Tochter
konnte es nicht glauben.
Sie sagte: "Das ist Wahnsinn!"
Hier kommt sie.
- Schau, Popcorn ist wieder da.
Wie fühlst du dich?
- Glücklich.- Du freust dich, was?
Ich wollte sie gar nicht mehr
hergeben und irgendwo verstecken.
Aber das hätte dir
sicher nicht gefallen.
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Endlich kann Laly
ihre Popcorn wieder streicheln.
Wir waren richtig glücklich,
dass wir Popcorn der Familie
und dem Mädchen zurückgeben konnten.
Sie verstanden dann sicher,
weshalb wir noch warten wollten.
Nun haben sie wieder
eine fast normale Katze.
Sie hat auch gekämpft.
- Ja.
Ich glaube,
wir nennen sie von nun an Warrior.
Ja, sie hat das gut gemacht.
- Genau.
Geniessen Sie die Zeit mit ihr.
- Danke.
Friss keine Wespen und Käfer mehr!
Es ist für Tierärzt:innen
teils schwer,
ihre kleinen Patienten
gehen zu lassen.
Machen Sie es gut.
- Vielen Dank.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Das Schönste ist,
wenn ein Tier wieder nach Hause darf
und nie mehr
in die Praxis zurückkehren muss.
* Muntere, beschwingte Musik *
Hallo.
* Lachen *
Hallo. Hallo, mein Grosser.
Sitz.
Ja, genau.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021
Hey, du sitzt auf meinem Fuss.
* Lachen *